hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
obviously on a podcast like mine we're
often going to be talking to scientists
of various sorts
theoretical scientists in particular
some of my favorites not all of them but
a lot of times we're talking about
the ideas for how we might explain some
scientific phenomenon right coming up
with a new theory whether it's a
dark matter or evolutionary biology or
whatever
it's going to be you might remember in
fact that i had lee smolin on the
podcast very recently
and despite the fact that we work in
very similar areas and we're personally
very friendly
we have different ideas about how to go
about building
the better next generation scientific
theories
why is that how can two scientists who
are both more or less trained in the
same way come up with very different
preferences
when it comes to building new
explanations that's what we're on about
today on today's podcast with simon
d'adeo
simon actually started as a theoretical
cosmologist much like myself but he
switched into
some combination of statistics and
data-driven social science
and cognitive science so it's a
wonderfully difficult specialty to pin
down but he's both at
carnegie mellon university and also the
santa fe institute
so we overlap a lot in our intellectual
interests and
what simon talks about in the paper that
we're going to be discussing today is
how explanations work and honestly
explanations in this sense
is kind of a synonym for a theoretical
viewpoint or formalism to answer some
kind of question
right so you have some phenomenon
whether it's my car broke down
or there's dark matter in the universe
and you want to explain it
now what happens is you can invent an
explanation and different people will
prefer
different kinds of explanations for
different reasons so what simon and his
collaborators have done is to break down
the different parts of bayesian analysis
that go into making a good explanation
and sort of
quantify different preferences or
different values you may have
for choosing your personal preferred
kind of explanation right
explanations have different kinds of
good aspects an explanation can be
simple it can be powerful it can be
close to things we already
understand it can explain many things at
once right these are all good things
but sometimes they fight against each
other sometimes an explanation can be
simple but not powerful it's simple for
only one phenomenon
or it's both simple and powerful but
utterly different than anything we know
so how to balance these is kind of a
human subjective thing right and we talk
about both how
scientists actually do this when you
have legitimate scientific
disagreements you know the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
versus the copenhagen interpretation or
pilot wave theories or something like
that what are the different values that
the
practitioners have that allow them to
prefer
in an intellectually respectable way
these different explanations in a
situation where we don't know which one
is right yet
and what's fascinating about simon's
analysis is it goes beyond
the case where everything's working
right you know i can say that i like
many worlds that's my favorite theory
but
i have absolute respect for people who
don't if they have principled reasons
for preferring some other things
sometimes people pick wrong explanations
because they're
failing at balancing these different
kinds of values
so there's sort of a continuum between
high-level
scientific discourse about unknown
theories and
complete crazy talk conspiracy theories
you know why do people believe
q anon or that school shootings or false
flag operations or something like that
well you can understand that in terms of
them putting
all of their eggs in one explanatory
basket all of their values are
concentrated on
comprehensiveness and rather than
simplicity or something like that so
it's not just that there are sensible
people in crackpots there's a continuum
of ways that we can try to explain the
world
and you can try to analyze the
similarities and differences between
conspiracy theorists and the world's
best theoretical physicists okay
it gives you a lot of food for thought
about how we go about explaining things
in our everyday lives so with that
let's go
simon todeo welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi sean
so we've had a lot of people at least a
few people talking about
misinformation disinformation uh
conspiracy theories that people fall in
love with things like that
and i think that what we'll be talking
about today
um you'll correct me if i'm not getting
this exactly right but
rather than focusing on that you know
the huge wrongness of believing in a
conspiracy theory or a crackpot scheme
we're thinking about explanations more
broadly
and and saying that there are people who
believe in conspiracy theories or
crackpot schemes but their
kind of belief the way they justify it
etc is of a piece
with perfectly respectable scientific
beliefs we should sort of
it's a matter of balancing things here
and there rather than a matter of a
completely different way of thinking is
that fair
yeah i you know um we've been we've been
working on these these questions for a
while
and uh one of the inspirations for me at
least
was you know a couple of years ago now
um
david deutsch wrote um a book called the
beginning of infinity right
and uh this is a love it's a lovely book
uh it's it's not
uh but it's it's lovely and uh
you know deutsche really focuses on
something that i had sort of
thought about but not as clearly for
many years which was
this idea that you explain things right
and that explanation is not simply you
know something we do to feel better
about the world but it's actually
this enormously generative process um
you know we had this problem uh you know
there was this was this puzzle for me
when i first started
working uh outside of physics because
people uh in biology want to predict
things or at least
the the outside world wants to predict
things biologists themselves
don't usually uh when we work on social
behavior people want to say can you
predict
the next war or whatever
and so deutsch really crystallized for
me the the way in which that's not
actually what what this game is about
and not only is it not what this game is
about it's like that's okay
right so um you know
the fact that we can't predict things um
you know especially not about the future
is uh is is not a sign that we're doing
something wrong but this time we're
doing something different
um so you know deutsch that was a sort
of way in and that kind of percolated in
my head for
for many years um when i got to cmu i
started working with a graduate student
zac voltowicz
um and you know zach and i played around
with a lot of different ideas
and um we started to think about you
know could we build
a a theory of explanation making
um you know this you know actually there
was another another impetus for this
which was uh
uh is a logician at cmu debbie borg and
so devi and i talked
for a while about uh there's this joke
right
why do mathematicians try to prove
things they already know are true
[Laughter]
right like this is the worst you know
science is about producing experiments
with uncertain outcomes so
you know what's the goal of a
mathematician um you know no one's
shocked
when fermat's last theorem has no
solution right
uh and so you know dave and i talked
about this and you know so
and you know just to dig a little into
this
um in science people have let's say try
to even formalize
what the next experiment you should do
is
right so this is called optimal
information design or it goes by any
different terms
uh so you can say you know should we
build you know the next hubble space
telescope or should we build the
lhc which one is going to give us more
information right and so you pick the
one that will give you more information
uh the one thing you shouldn't do is do
an experiment where you are guaranteed
to know the outcome
yeah so then you know we talk and you
know debbie and i talking say well
what's
why does a mathematician care about
proving something they already know is
true
and debbie's answer is you know
something like p versus np
right these really challenging problems
one of the intuitions is that the
solution
is going to discover unexpected
connections between very different
branches of mathematics
so it'll give us a new view onto things
we thought we understood because of the
way in which
these different chunks have to be
brought together i mean so
this is very uh relevant to my interests
as they say on the internet
because of course in quantum mechanics
we have a situation where
generations of physicists have been
brainwashed into thinking that we don't
need to understand what's happening
all we need to do is make the
predictions for the outcomes of
observations
and the uh counter example i try to say
is look what if you had a black box
into which you could ask literally any
outcome of a specific physical situation
does that count as solving all of
physics right you know
anything you want to know but you have
to re-ask it it doesn't tell you what
the theory is it just tells you
when you collide these two billiard
balls they scatter off at this
particular angle
i don't think that counts as a good
theory of physics we want the theory for
reasons beyond that
right right right right um right so you
know if we're if we're building a theory
of how
exactly how to shake the box like we
have a goal in shaking the box in a
certain way right and
then the question is yeah what's what's
the goal how do we know when we've
reached that goal
um how do we know if we're on the right
track and so
you know someone like deutsch uh you
know articulates this fact that you know
what we care about is explanations
then you know zach and i dig in and we
say all right let's
let's try to build you know this is a
joke here right let's try to build a
unified
theory of explanation-making um
and you know this then this then rolls
into a year
of of enormous fun right um
trying to make sense of the ways in
which you have a whole bunch of
different experiments
that we do for example lab experiments
on people and you know in a cyclab right
where we say
um and this is not my work tanya
lombroso's one of the big figures in
this so
um you know you might you might say tell
somebody okay look there's this alien
right
these aliens and you know they fall
victim to these kinds of diseases
and this disease gives these symptoms
and that disease gives that symptom
and you know this alien comes into your
consulting room and he has you know
spots
and a cough and you know diagnose this
alien
and you can look at the different
choices people make in a sense a
diagnosis
by proxy is an explanation for the
symptoms
that the person brings in or the alien
brings in and so by looking at the
choices they make in attributing
let's say a pair of diseases or a single
disease to the alien
you learn a lot about the kind of
preferences we have the ways
in which we select explanations one one
from another
and let me just to be super duper clear
we're using the word explanation here
almost in the sense of a theory or a
model right it's not like someone says
well
explain black holes to me and we think
we know what black holes are but there's
this pedagogical
uh attempt to explain them in a
comprehensible way you're using the word
explanation to really mean
uh knowledge of what is going on behind
the scenes that
that could help us and then we can sort
of choose between competing explanations
that can't all be right
right so this is this is great right so
um you know our
our model is a bayesian model meaning we
ask questions about
the things we have to hand let's say the
facts in the world and we ask
the ways in which they match the models
we have of the world
and so it's a very specific kind of
model it's a generative model which
says it gives you degrees of belief in
the things that could happen
um so in that sense you know we've
really boiled it down
to a paradigm that you know in one sense
doesn't really match any kind of science
we do
right like uh you know condensed matter
physics is not a generative model in the
sense that
it specifies the probability of
different things happening sorry what is
the definition of a generative model
ah right so um a generative model
tells you not just the things that might
happen
uh or the things that could happen but
also gives you degrees of likelihood
okay
for the different things that could
happen um
it's a way you can think of it as like a
mini simulation that you have controls
over right so you can see inside the
simulator
and that simulator you push a button and
it projects a possible world under the
screen
right so but you asked us you know when
you ask sean
what is an explanation more broadly
this gets into a big question that let's
say
we can split into two parts right
an explanation has to do with empirical
facts
right it's it's a way of accounting for
stuff that has happened
right or stuff you know um but it's also
an account of how that stuff could have
happened
and generally it's a it's an account of
other things that
might happen other things you could look
for uh
other things that could happen in the
future or happening somewhere else
so there's sort of two p there's sort of
two pieces when we think about an
explanation
one piece when we evaluate one right one
piece is
you know you asked me to explain this
right
can you meaning can you tell me a story
of in some way in which the thing that
happened comes true
sure right so that's kind of this
empirical piece right and then this
other piece that's sitting there which
is this much
sort of troubling piece um is how do i
feel about the larger structure of that
explanation
including the things it might do um
for things that could happen in the
future let's say things that i haven't
observed yet
uh also things like what does the
explanation look like how succinct is it
how concise is it
uh versus how elaborate it is so when we
refer to things like occam's razor
what we're talking about is that second
chunk right
right of the ways in which we might
value an explanation
hiring people for your business is as
much about who you say yes to as who you
say no to
but it sure helps when you can narrow
down the list to only really
great choices first so you're not
choosing between good and bad
but good and great that's what you get
with indeed
indeed is the job site that makes hiring
as easy as one two three
post screen and interview all on indeed
you can get your quality short list of
candidates whose resumes on indeed
match your job description faster only
pay for the candidates that meet your
must have qualifications
and schedule and complete video
interviews in your indeed dashboard
indeed makes connecting with and hiring
the right talent fast and easy
with tools like indeed instant match and
indeed skills tests
that on average reduces hiring time by
27
you can choose from more than 130 skills
tests then add your must have
requirements
so that you only pay for applications
that meet them get started right now
with a free
75 sponsored job credit to upgrade your
job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through june 30th
terms and conditions apply
and in some this is going to be very
vague and then you'll fix it but
uh one of the nice things about your way
of talking about explanations is it is
bayesian like you said
and you know we talk about bayesian
stuff on the podcast all the time so the
folks have heard the term but uh all we
really need is the idea that there's a
prior
there's some pre-existing probability or
credence that the
model is right and then you update
because information comes in
and what what you do in some sense is
sort of
decompose those two parts the prior part
and the
likelihood part into different values
that an explanation can have is that
fair
right yeah so you know um we we put
explanations into the super collider we
spin them really fast
and it turns out that what we thought
right were two things they're actually
let's say at least four things right
tell us what the fourth thing
and um sorry tell us those four things
i will i will tell you right um you know
the human curiosity is infinite right
so um and you know of course what does
it mean to
to diagnose or just to discover these
sub-pieces of a mathematical equation
uh you know what we're really doing is
saying this piece
picks up on a psychological value
so in fact our minds are sensitive let's
say not
just to the prior and the posterior
right
the things you knew beforehand and how
well you do on the next bit
but also these little pieces right so um
for example in the case of the the
empirical side of
the evaluation of explanations uh we
split into two pieces one is
descriptiveness we call it
descriptiveness is just how likely is
the stuff that happened
taken individually given your
explanation
right so i've got a whole bunch of
things that happen i want you to explain
right um you give me an explanation
if i pick let's say any piece of what
i've seen at random
how well does the explanation doing so
as a as opposed to
sorry let me back up because we're
trying to convert into words something
that is
mathematically very clear if we can see
the equation in front of us which which
we can't
right right so in the in basis theorem
there's this idea of the likelihood
which is to say
the probability that you would be
getting that evidence
if this particular explanation were the
right one and
i think what i hear you saying is yes
that's a thing
but we're going to divide that up we're
going to divide this
probability of getting the evidence
given the explanation into
first the probability of getting this
particular
piece of data is that right that's right
yeah
okay so um you know i have a story
about let's say um
gosh now i'm now i'm on the spot let's
think of a good one
um uh i have a story about
why my food tastes this way okay let's
say and
it's hot and it's salty right so i have
a certain explanation
and let's say that um it's hot and
salty because i put it in the oven right
now that explanation does really well
to explain why it's hot right it doesn't
do so well to explain why it's salty
right
um i might also say it's hot and salty
because i put it in the oven and then i
salted it right so now
okay i've what i've done is i've
explained two things in the world
in some sense i've explained them
somewhat separately yeah right
so i've i've accounted for this fact
with this part of the explanation this
other fact with this other part of the
explanation
and in that case sort of trivially the
only value
the only empirical value there is what
we call descriptiveness because it does
just as well
explaining one part of the data as the
other part
as in fact both parts together okay
so there's a different piece though here
that's coming in or that comes in
which is and maybe this is a better way
to say it sean some explanations link
things together
yeah right some explanations not only
say what's happening but also say this
thing happening
is in some way correlated with this
other thing happening
right so i can put food in the oven
right or i can salt the food
but these two things in that explanation
aren't really dependent upon each other
right right so my explanation hasn't
linked together these two things right
um there are explanations that do link
things together
uh so and i mean i know you're more the
foodie than i am right like
don't you like salt crust and cook
something
right like there's some way that like
when you cook something in salt it's
better i don't know help me sean right
yeah i don't understand there is
picked a tough example i think the best
the best explanation i can think of is
you put salt in it and then you put it
in the oven sorry
sorry put it in the oven right right
maybe you're cooking it in like pure
lit like literally sodium right um you
know maybe you're cooking it pittsburgh
style right
where the salting and the heating is
something that you know has to go
together
um in that case the reason it's hot and
it's salty is it's being cooked
pittsburgh style
but the and if it's yeah so
i think that we would agree so good so
what we're doing here is taking
terms and an equation basis theorem and
we're
relating them to human values we like it
when uh if you just said on the street
do you like explanations that that cover
many things at once and link them
together people would say yes and now
you're
able to identify where that value is
expressed
in vases theorem but what's interesting
to me here is that this idea that the
explanation can link
the data together is in the what you're
calling the empirical
part it's not in the prior it's not just
part of saying well it's a simple
cohesive theory of everything that's
ordinarily what i would think
of as living in the prior credence
before we collect any evidence at all
right right so um this is great um i
should say sean i have a better example
which i think will work much better
rewind or should we just
plow onwards plow onward because we can
see the
gears turning people it's good for
people okay good good
good we can thinking live um
so your intuition's not crazy right um
there is something about this feature we
call co-explanation
which is how it links things that we've
observed together
and that seems to be linked to just how
the theory would do in general
right um it's a that's something we call
in fact we have a name for it we call it
unification
um the critical part here and this is
you know it's in some sense a trivial
distinction
is that co-explanation only deals with
the facts
you have to hand okay not necessarily
the facts that you could get
in the future right so it's simply
uh you know somebody presents you a
scenario or a situation with a bunch of
features in it um he may also present
you with different kinds of explanations
that make the observed things dependent
upon each other
or not okay right so
it's you know in some sense this is very
you know sort of blinkered view of the
world
it's only one part um so
what do we have so far we yeah in other
words let's imagine that there were
50 different ways i could characterize
the food i'm eating
and i had a theory that only had two
inputs
that explained all 50 of them uh but if
the two that i had actually measured
were saltiness and
and heat and those two needed both the
two inputs to explain them
then at that level i haven't really
co-explained anything even though the
theory
in itself was quite simple and unified
uh for these particular data it was it
was not doing
that particular value right exactly
so your theory would be let's say high
in
unification right right it's it's it's
making a lot of promises
right it's tempting you right it says
you know let's go out there uh
and see and you know at some point we're
going to come up to the to the dark side
of this so
q anon certainly has this feature it's
like you know
there's a lot of things that might be
linked and
i wonder what you'll find if you look
for yourself right so there
are these kind of promises that theories
make and the promises of course they're
deeply satisfying when they pay off
right and so i think about when i teach
um
that co-explanatory moment is a lovely
moment right
it's um you know you've thought this
like i've been telling you this now
check this out and you pull you know you
you pull away the curtain and lo and
behold people see
this thing in a new light and they
understand the old thing
and the new thing is being somehow
linked together i remember
telling my friends in undergraduate
school you know
what i learned is that uh when you do a
lorenz transformation in special
relativity like you move to a different
reference frame
it's just like doing a rotation in space
except it's in space-time and you could
see them go like
oh why didn't they tell us that that's
awesome right like it's
it's unifying these two different things
yeah i mean i i you know sean it's funny
i'm trying to think of a better example
so let me let me give you one
so we can maybe use it as we go forward
right uh let's instead of food let's see
being hot versus salty
uh let's imagine you have an
undergraduate okay and you see they've
taken
a class in let's say french and
a class in neuroscience right
and so you know one explanation is
they're interested in french
they're interested in neuroscience right
so
these two facts are not dependent upon
each other you can basically like french
you know independently of neuroscience
but another explanation would be
this is a linguistics major right
okay right there is now this common
explanation
that says you're a linguistics major the
fact that you took
neuroscience is connected to the fact
that you took french
right um you know the discovery of
majors
right enables you to make sense of what
all the undergraduates were doing in
that school these kind of hidden common
causes
driving the classes they're showing up
so i think i am getting it
the the virtue or the value that we're
pinpointing here is not
just the simplicity of the underlying
explanation but the fact that it relates
these two particular facts that we have
that we have seen it's not just that it
explains both it actually relates them
to each other
in it one doesn't move if the other
doesn't move right
good that sort of thing right um you
know you have a
you know sore throat and a runny nose
right yep one answer could be you have
allergies and you were screaming right
another explanation could be you have
one of these things right you have a
virus
okay um there's one thing i'm gonna put
so it's funny because
you you did the same thing i did when we
first started working on this which is
you said oh
and a co-explanatory theory
is also a simple one but it's not
right so you can have some enormous
cascade of coincidence you know of like
i'll tell you why you know the bus
was late and you know your watch was
broken
it's because there's a malevolent
conspiracy that is you know chasing you
through the world
arranging things so that the guy who
fixed your watch timed it to break
and stop the bus and yes that does make
these facts in the world dependent upon
each other
it's a deeply non simple theory or even
if you just had
a hundred different kinds of data and
your theory was that
data one is correlated in this way with
data two always and data two is always
correlated with
three in this way and it just goes one
with a hundred different correlations
independently then you've co-explained
everything but you don't have a simple
theory
you've co-explained the pairs right so
if you think about it right like now now
just imagine filling out that pyramid
right so
these two things are co-explained by
this cause and these two things are
co-explained by this cause
those those hidden things there those
two causes maybe they're co-explained
right so now you get this like big
branching tree where you know everything
goes back to
you know the god head or something um
but your instinct's not wrong right
because
you know if your your first thought was
wow but it's simple it's kind of cool
right that
these two things are dependent upon each
other and i think now it's kind of a
nice
situation here where we see that the
things we like
may lead us astray yeah right if
if somebody you know leads you to
perceive these two things are correlated
we kind of like it right we think oh you
know that's elegant that's simple
simplicity
is a value right but you know let's yeah
hold on a second right because maybe
there's some other pieces here that are
in play right and this of course this
was the odyssey of discovery for us
um is is realizing that
a lot of things that we think of as
values
are you know or a lot of things we think
of as good things are actually
combinations of values
right and they're combinations let's say
of well-weighted values right so this is
you know you want to cook a good
explanation don't put
you know too much fish sauce in right
like a little goes a long way
and so um you know so it was difficult
for us at first
to kind of break apart our own values i
mean i won't speak for zach like but for
me it was difficult to break apart our
own values
to start to see how things you know
could go right or could go wrong along
each of these axes well that's right so
these are values in not only just
uh value neutral values but they're
they're good values we would like to be
able to co-explain we like to be able to
be descriptive
but they're going to compete against
each other that's going to be the trick
so right so we have on the table
descriptiveness co-explanation
what are the other values excellent all
right so let's
let's sweep over to the let's call the
theoretical side
theoretical values those were the values
we're doing the
empirical side and now we're doing the
theoretical side
exactly right so you know
descriptiveness co-explanation it's all
about
you know show me the money right show me
the data let's see
what the explanation is doing for the
stuff that's causing us
all these problems right so then let's
go over to the theoretical side
we split this into two parts right um
one part we called domain dependent
value
uh let's i'll tell you what i promise i
will tell you what that is in a second
the other part we called and you'll be
happy we we call this simplicity that's
good right
um so let's dig into the easy one which
is domain dependent value
demand dependent value is your
intuition's just about the stuff the
explanation is about
right so you know the example the car
mechanic right
you bring your car in and it's like oh
yes it's a volkswagen those years
it's the installation that goes bad
right so
these kinds of experiences their
intuition it's tacit knowledge it's all
of these things
that go into your sense of how the world
works in this domain right so
most of our domain dependent values
they're invisible until you change
fields right and you'll get really upset
because you
present a biologist with a theory that
explains all the data
and it's really beautiful and they're
like that's just not how life works
like it just doesn't work that way and
you're like
tell me and they're like you have to
actually do this right for
10 years 20 years um so
that that's that's a real part it's a
it's a real part that's sitting there
it's obviously a bit harder to study in
the lab um
because either everybody has the same
domain dependent values we all have the
same like folk physics
folk biology you know sort of stories
about the way the world works
um and then of course in the things we
know very well we have very specific
values but it's you know it's tough to
get enough car mechanics in the lab
at the same time to understand how these
these so i mean is this how does this
relate to the idea that if we have a new
idea or some specific explanation
it should try to cohere and be
compatible with things that we already
think are true
elsewhere is that the same idea or
related idea
i think we really wanted to keep this
kind of simple right um we wanted to say
this is just how likely do you think
explanations of this pattern are you may
have some deep theory
right but let's go back to the the car
mechanic right
there's you know 50 different models of
cars you work on cars long enough
you learn that the volkswagen has this
insulation problem and the subaru tends
to have a piston problem
it this is not fitting into some grand
theory about car manufacturing and you
know
the the industry it might if you were a
certain kind of car mechanic but
by and large you know you're working off
of you know
let's say uh you know doesn't have to be
stimulus response but just things you've
noticed and
remembered um maybe there's some pattern
recognition involved but we really
wanted to kind of
keep this as almost an untheorized chunk
right
these are the things that make the
biologists say life doesn't work that
way and then you say
why and they're like i you know get out
of my office right
it's one thing to start exercising again
it's another thing to keep it up as a
regular habit
with world-class instructors curated
music and endless fitness variety
peloton has created an unmatched fitness
experience
to keep you motivated workout after
workout with epic artist collaborations
and instructor curated playlists
peloton's music experience is unlike any
other
whether you're in the mood for some
hip-hop pop or country the peloton bike
has the right music to keep you
entertained and motivated all year long
and whether you're looking for some
extra encouragement structured workouts
or just in the mood to laugh the peloton
instructors
are there to bring out your best during
each class
from beginner programs to tabata
intervals peloton meets you at every
step in your fitness journey as you
progress
choose from a wide range of cycling
classes that meet your level
and keep you challenged every time you
clip in so get started on your peloton
journey go to
one peloton dot com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e
so let me let me try another example so
um you and i both used to be
cosmologists
we've moved on in our lives but uh
something that cosmologists often do is
to say
well maybe there's some scalar field or
some modification of gravity some you
know
new fundamental physics that stretches
out that affects things in galaxies and
clusters that we've never noticed here
in the lab
and you tell this to particle physicists
or to quantum field theorists and
they're like
no effective field theories don't work
that way you know you don't have weird
things showing up at long distances in
the infrared that wouldn't show up
at short distances we're pretty
confident in the in the long distances
is that an example that that's
that's a good example um i think
let's uh let's push even further away
from you know particle physicists let's
say have stories about how effective
field theories work
but you know okay you want a physicist
i'll give you a physicist so scott
aronson has a wonderful blog post
about why i won't read your proof that p
equals np or p not equal mp right right
and um you know it's a kind of long list
right
and none of these i actually have to
remember but you know most of these
reasons do not involve
his theories about the way p versus np
work right
sure um these these um you know one of
his great examples
is um if you're using mathematics that i
just don't think is powerful enough
right like category fit no right
category theory is not going to do this
now it isn't because you know scott has
tried or has some great theory about why
category theory won't work he's just
like
that you know it's that's a you know
it's great but
it's that's it's just sandbox stuff
compared to what you would need
well scott of course former mindscape
guest um
uh more recent mindscape guest julia
galliff she and i were talking about
the uh how one deals with crackpot
theories in
physics right and the point being so i
have a way of dealing with crackpot
theories in physics as a physicist but
she says you know she's not a physicist
so how
should she approach grandiose claims
from people she doesn't know and
because she's not a physicist she has to
rely on
signals from the person who has the
theory
right like do they recognize the
problems that their theory has
are they willing to say they might be
wrong or are they just like
no i'm oppressed by the system and i'm a
genius that no one else has ever been
before and
so i mean that's a different kind of
domain specific knowledge right it's
almost like the psychological domain
like what are the features that you're
likely to have in a crackpot versus a
respectable scientist
exactly i think that's even uh that's
that's a nice example because it really
gets
at um the untheorized version
here right so you know and then there's
nothing wrong with the geocities web
page
in the 1990s like john baez had a
geocities webpage and he talked about
like the fundamental theories of physics
um so you know when you turned on that
page and it was you know
i mean john probably didn't have this
right it's the animated gif of like the
flames and the under construction sign
and it says
you know how to understand finding
diagrams you're like
great here we go right the same
literally the same website
in 2020 it's like this is you know don't
right stay away
yeah so you know and i think there's you
know again when i'm
well and i i'm not sure i want to put
zach on the spot here but you know my
sense is is that these domain dependent
priors
a lot of this is much more what we might
call tacit knowledge
right the stuff you know but you can't
say right so you know
julia when she says okay i have to watch
the person you know
she's not crazy right there's good
reasons to do that
um but you know when uh
you know scott says ah category theory
is just not powerful enough you're like
well you know can you can you tell me
why and he's like i
just really feel you know like i've been
juggling these things for years
so and so this is great it's funny shot
i you know zach and i didn't spend too
much time on this
uh this part partly because we had a
word limit um
but you know the domain dependent price
are there and they matter right
um the other piece right this is where
all the excitement starts showing up
right because this is where we start
judging what you might call the
aesthetics of a theory
so not how it does on the data to hand
not whether it fits your gut right and
your gut meaning your experiences
of you know empirical life but the ways
in which
the theory looks right um
if you dig deep enough into this things
get very strange and it's sort of
beautifully strange
um you know we uh we talked about
many different values that fall under
let's say the simplicity value
um succinctness right like
literally how short is the explanation
right
um you know can you say it in five
words or less right um you know my dad
used to say if someone can't tell you
what their job is in a sentence they
don't have a real job
right that's maybe a little unfair but
you know succinctness
is is something that might tell you
whether the explanation is
is a good one right why were you late oh
okay so
probably this is not you know you're you
believe this explanation
just because it takes a long time so
unfair
maybe right um you know concision
a slightly more advanced version that
talks about okay maybe you switch
languages here or you know is it concise
in this language you know does the
lorenz transform look particularly
elegant and
hyperbolic tan universe right um
we can talk about uh unification for
example
um which is the way it links things
together we can count the number of
hidden causes
right we can say you know your example
of there's a hundred things and they're
each pairwise linked together and then
we link all the pairs together and we
know okay fine it's log number of things
causes roughly um so
the the you know just counting causes
right
um occam's razor you know we debate this
a little bit but
one simple thing is to count parameters
right how many parameters are in your
theory if you have a mathematical theory
um when i was a grad student i gave a
talk on my you know
latest dumb scalar energy theory and
who was it some famous physicist said
how many parameters does your theory
have and i've said like whatever three
i just walked out right because i was
just too many parameters
for him right it was you know didn't
matter what i could explain you know it
didn't matter you know how everything
would link everything together it's just
that's too many parameters yeah i got to
walk my dog
so you're like i'm leaving i'm going to
social science
right well and so i mean you know there
are some interesting
we'll talk a little bit about the social
science stuff because there's some
interesting stuff that happens there
with respect to simplicity
um you know you can keep digging though
so take the take the value
of uh of succinctness right
um one way is to say not just the
sinkness in english
you know but like succinctness in and
here we go
right succinctness in the computer
program
that if you ran it would print the
explanation out in the language you can
read right
um this you know has claimed to being in
some sense
you know the right definition of
simplicity or
let's say you know sort of concision or
succinctness
because it makes it sort of language
independent right
um we know roughly speaking that
whatever language you write in it won't
change that value
very much so you write your code to
generate the model in python versus list
versus c you know it's maybe a constant
offset right
so this this idea um and it's called
comagora of complexity
uh also called uh uh chaitlin complexity
there's many different names for it
um because partly it was you know
invented during the during the cold war
um we had many people in the west and
they had kolmogorov
and so he gets his name on literally
everything yeah but so
let's call it let's call karma gravity
so um
you know this is this in one sense is
the ultimate value if we could perceive
this value
right we would know that true simplicity
of an explanation right now
should we value that true simplicity
maybe right let's put that question
aside and just say you know whether it's
a virtue or not let's just say
how could we come to know that value and
it turns out it's
logically impossible that you could know
this value
right we can say what it is right
but unless you're like roger penrose and
you think
that humans in some sense transcend you
know the turing
world if we're not you know if we can't
be efficiently or in fact
inefficiently simulated by a computer uh
you know unless you think that uh we
have no contact with this value
it is uncomputed it's a value it's
uncomputable right and
you know i go on about this in length
uncomputable means uncomputable and you
can't
compute it anyway right so you can't
approximate this value because any
approximation you do will have
unknown error and then you say fine i
will compute the error which of course
is uncomputable
right and so actually this is a very
good
uh opportunity for me to make sure i
understand this because you know scott
and i wrote a paper scott aronson
and we we need to mention the fact that
kolmogorov complexity is uncomputable
and i didn't understand it and
he finally taught it to me so let me see
if i remember uh i mean because the
obvious counter-argument is
given any language i will just write
every computer program from the shortest
one to the longest one or you know
i will keep writing you know longer
longer computer programs until i output
the output i want to get
and the reason why that fails is because
of the halting problem because you will
eventually hit computer programs that
never terminate
and you don't know whether it will
terminate or not
so if you if you and you're in your
enumeration of every computer program
if you don't actually by luck output
what you're looking for you will never
be able to get to what you're looking
for
right exactly um that's that's that's
one way it's you know
all of the you know your way is blocked
at every turn right it's like the you
know the dungeons and dragons game
and the you know the dm is logic and the
dm like you can't get out of the room
so every door you try uh there is
some problem with it right so your
example right
is oh if you just enumerate every
computer program
then eventually you'll hit one that will
never stop this is the halting problem
right so okay
the whole thing problem blocks you that
way um
some you know people have different sort
of creative solutions for how to solve
this
every creative solution runs into a kind
of girdle-like problem
right every girdle-like problem secretly
is a problem of self-reference
and so we're saying that simplicity is a
something that we hold in great value
but we can't really quantify it
right it's like you know it's the it's
the don't cancel me sean it's the
atheist god right
like it's the negative theology of the
ultimate theory
we will never know we actually might
have it already right but we can never
know that we have it got it okay um
you know so i mean just to drive the
intuition here um i've i'd love you know
you can transform this into the halting
problem
another thing you can say is and this is
uh what's called barry's paradox right
um you know you you have some way to
name
all the numbers okay fine the shortest
number that you can't you know
or the smallest number you can't name in
less than 50 000 words right
i have just named that number in you
know less than 50 000 words so there's
some paradox here
in talking about how difficult it is to
name things
yeah in part because when you name
things you can also talk about names
so that's the kind of self-referential
aspect here
if we were somehow able to ban all
self-reference from our theories
we could actually compute the simplicity
but i'm not sure we want to do that
right because most good theories
in some sense can refer back to
themselves right
in you know i guess in some very simple
physics theories that may not be the
case right
if they're you know sitting purely as
you know
a set of let's say discrete update
equations
it may be possible to think about the
shortest way to specify them
yeah um but if you uh you know you could
say okay look what's the
you know what's the context freelance oh
no because those are
uncomputable as well it's r it's really
hard right it's really hard to have
theories that are boring enough such
that you can know with absolute
confidence their simplicity so i guess
the only way i can think of is like a
markov model right markov models we
actually do know
right we can sort of compute how simple
they are
okay but at the end of the day where we
are here is
you have enumerated denumerated
uh four values so to remind everyone
the descriptiveness the co-explanation
the domain-specific
knowledge was it domain-specific prior
domain specific
and the simplicity so these are the
things that we look for in an
explanation and when i read your list
it reminded me there was a famous or
semi-famous list that thomas kuhn came
up with i don't know if you're familiar
with this but
you know when when kuhn wrote the
structure of scientific revolutions and
said well there are paradigm shifts and
you can't even judge one paradigm from
within another one
he was accused by his detractors of
being a relativist of saying no
scientific knowledge or progress is
possible etc and
he didn't think of himself that way so
he wrote a follow-up
piece where he said well no i'm just
saying kind of there's no algorithm for
doing it but there are values that we
have and he listed seven values
and i forget what they were but um but
one of them was fruitfulness
like if the theory would not only
explain what it's explaining but it has
the promise of explaining
other things so my question is um
does your list of four values um purport
to be
it is it comprehensive and exhaustive
are these the values that we have when
it comes to explanation or are they
some of them uh how should we think
about that
right right so um i would say kuhn's
uh fruitfulness is probably our
unification
uh unification being the co-explanation
you'd get
if you observed lots of other stuff and
the theory turned out to be true
right okay um so uh so that's you know
it's a piece there we
we we give it a name um the
you know in the end it would be nice if
you know it would be nice if we had a
normative theory of explanation meaning
we know which ones we we know when we've
got it right
really what we have here is a
psychological theory right we're
interested
in the axes along which a theory can get
better or worse
uh that we perceive right so it's a
little bit i mean you know the extreme
version would be like okay like
it can be salty it can be sweet right
right um
how is you know how do we as explainers
human explainers
look at the world um or and look at
explanations
then you can say okay well maybe we're
not so bad at it because
you know as david deutsch says we have
we're amazing
infinitely capable creatures um you know
maybe we're on to something
in having these values but uh
you know we can also over and
undervalue them so there's a nice you
know a line
here right uh values can be both virtues
and vices we can value the wrong things
or we can value them too much
or too little right so you know kuhn's
list of seven
i wouldn't be surprised if many of them
aligned
with you know the pieces we have
he may have found others that don't
align that way you know a couple things
could be going on one is he could be
wrong
right um another is that he could have a
psychological
value that for him is very real
but that he has learned so another piece
here
that we have is that we can not only not
only do we have sort of let's say
baked in values so when you study
children uh you discover
psychologists who study this discover
that you know children like
co-explanation right they like sweet
things and they like co-explanation
so some of these are kind of baked in um
but others are sort of trainable right
so you know it's probably the case that
you know you and i as people who like
physics
um you know had a heavy weight on
certain values let's say
the unification value the simplicity
value but
you know it was exaggerated over time
right because
all of our charismatic teachers you know
gave us you know
candy when we we valued simplicity more
um you know conversely anthropologists
uh you know value simplicity less and
it's in part because they know the world
is not that simple when it comes to
people
so i remember there was a simulation i
saw people doing a simulation
of um you know the
you know civilization developing in the
american southwest um
you know pre pre-contact and you know
they had this
model where there were people on a
landscape and choosing where to walk and
choosing where to settle and build
you know houses and and i'm sitting
there i'm sort of boiling with
with upsetness as a physicist i was just
new to the santa fe and stupid this was
happening at the time i was like this is
terrible right like
they're that you know there's two kinds
of houses you know how many parameters
does this theory have
and then this great anthropologist
raised his hand one of the big big
figures and he's like
but where are the where are the turkeys
right why don't you have the wild
turkeys in the simulation because that's
important
right and um he was right right that
matters right that's an important part
of explaining what's going on where the
turkeys are
but um you know with somebody with a
different set of values would say
this is just getting too extreme like we
need a different
like this the fact that we're adding
these things into the explanation is
making it worse and not better well i
guess so
i mean this this is one of the things i
wanted to ask because you have these
different values
and as you just highlighted very clearly
in the real world they compete um
sometimes anyway
like i mean obviously if there's one
theory that is both simpler
and more co-explanatory and more
descriptive it will win
uh but sometimes the theory is less
simple but more descriptive etc and then
you have to balance and that's
harder um so i guess two questions one
is
does the right way to balance these
values
pop out of bayes theorem or something
like that have you mathematically proven
the right way
or um question number two
can we empirically figure it out like
can you go back in the history of
science and say well
this person was valuing simplicity and
this person was valuing their domain
specific priors and
look who won and sort of towed up a
scorecard
um yes so well let's say partly
um we have we have a story about the
proper waiting between
descriptiveness and co-explanation right
there's a proper ratio in which you
should value these okay ratio and units
in the correct units is one
right um so you should value these two
things equally in a certain way
but you know the real challenge here
is when it comes to the
theoretical values what we don't have
is a normative let's say or the optimal
or the ideal way
to talk about the theoretical values
okay right
um there are people who will tell you
that for example uh simplicity has to be
a value
and you say well why does simplicity
have to be a value and you talk to them
long enough and it turns out it's
because the universe is simple
right okay right how do you know it's
simple well it turns out that's the
simplest explanation
for why right okay so um there
you know the on on that side we don't
have a
we don't have an answer but you ask of
course the right question is can we just
go
see how people do right can we see
how well people who valued this kind of
explanation over that one how they've
done
in historical time so we're actually we
have a project on this it's really fun
uh we have all the data from the
proceedings of the royal society
the royal society of london so this is
the first scientific institution
uh it's formed in 1666 or at least the
journal starts then
uh 16 16. it's uh sorry the society
started in 1660. i know that's
literally reading about it yesterday
excellent okay
journal starts a little bit later um
maybe i can't remember now it's like
1663 right this is why i drive
historians crazy
um you know it's it's it starts on the
order of 10 to the
you know three years after the price
um so uh we have this data
the on essentially how scientists are
putting ideas together
over time and how do we track the ideas
we do some magical pattern recognition
on the text
we look at the patterns we find um
we as scientists say okay these patterns
are making sense
right so we can detect the you know
magnetism idea we can detect the
electricity idea we can detect the
uh magnetic substances topic which is a
different one right it's like
you know magnetism what's up with that
right and it's it's sort of sad because
our data only goes to
the late 1800s 1887 so
we know they're not going to figure out
why iron becomes magnetic
until the 20th century like it's not
it's just not going to happen for you
right
and so you sort of feel bad like you
want to say no
other things they do figure out though
of course and famously what they figure
out is that there is this you know
global conspiracy
between the electric and the magnetic
fields which we call the electromagnetic
field
um these uh
forms and it's tricky to call them
co-explanation because
these are not these topics or these
ideas are not just about the observed
things but also discussions of the ideas
themselves
but we can track how these ideas link
together
over time uh the first thing you find is
that this value at least in science
kind of appears out of nowhere right so
the first hundred years
of science is people putting ideas
together
in somewhat arbitrary ways now it could
be they
you know it could be they know that
ideas should be linked together
and no one's agreed on how to link them
together so they may have the value
uh or perhaps more likely i would say
um they haven't yet learned that what
you should be doing is finding the ideas
that tend to link together and working
on those
right so preferring and in fact we can
see this happening
preferring to work on ideas that
reliably connect
to particular other ideas so this is
kind of wild right
uh we can see uh people moving towards
and it starts this preference starts
around
early 1800s actually one of the first
people
one of the the issue in which it starts
is the issue in which
they publish ben franklin's kite
experiment um
you know can we dated that precisely no
right but that's where the bayesian
model says right
um great pennsylvania physicist uh
but you know beginning around the early
1800s
we have this era which lasts maybe about
100 years um maybe 50 years we have this
era
where people start connecting ideas
together
so uh people know oh idea a
has something to do with idea b and not
c right
right um whereas you know earlier you
look 50 years before
100 years before they're like
earthquakes cows
maybe cows right you know and you're
like no right it's not that's not going
to happen
but at some point they start putting
these ideas together
the let's say the overall unification
level in science starts to rise
uh we can also see people as i said
people
choosing to work in on areas
that are linking together right so we
see this emergence right of a value or
at least
the value begins to articulate itself uh
in the right can i
with you with respect to that yeah this
might
be relevant to a very long-standing
puzzle that i've
wondered about which was because uh my
first trade book from eternity to here
was on entropy
and i read a lot about boltzmann and
maxwell and their discussions etc
and one of the big um objections to
boltzmann
was he was deriving the second law of
thermodynamics that entropy increases as
a probabilistic statement but it wasn't
absolute
and people thought it should be absolute
they thought it was a law they thought
it was a law
separate from newton's laws of classical
mechanics
and that always puzzled me like how were
you allowed to think that like you know
there was the same stuff
right like how could a gas obey newton's
laws and the second law if they weren't
compatible with each other and
are you telling me that maybe that
possible incompatibility just wasn't
something that would
uh throw itself in their faces and make
them bothered by it at that point in
scientific history
that's that's great i mean it's funny
sean um
one of the papers in our data i mean
it's a bit ironic is baze's original
paper
right so the reverend base publishes his
article
and it's an amazing article it's
actually it was he died and somebody
said
baze told me the following um it's an
amazing article because actually
everything's in there
right so the idea that models uh make
probabilistic predictions the idea that
you can go both directions
right that you can go from uh from model
to
data data to model it's all sitting in
there
but somehow this just didn't catch fire
for people
right the the idea that knowledge could
be probabilistic
right that this was a good
representation of what we know or how to
know things
um just didn't take off um you know
bayes is
that you know those ideas are sitting
there and don't get linked which is sort
of interesting right
um so in one sense i can tell you you're
right no one
connected these together um you know in
that case
you know how do you punt it you might
punt that to the domain priors
right newton is about precision right
uh newtonian laws are about determinism
the solar system will go forever
uh running like a clock so somehow the
idea that
you know there would be some
relationship between newton's
you know that style and you know
probabilistic
reasoning it's a little bit like you
know the scott aronson idea that that's
just not powerful enough but in this
case it's like
no that's just not the right thing we've
been doing this for 200 years
but they were just wrong right um
so i think that's that's a lovely
example sean i mean it's easy for us to
focus
on the successes um you know the obvious
one is
we can see them put electricity and
magnetism together which is a beautiful
thing
um we also see them put electricity
and electrochemistry together which is
an interesting one
because electricity is more the theory
electrochemistry is the experiment so we
can start to see people
you see what uh joel moker calls this
this virtuous cycle between
uh uh theory and experiment right better
theories let you build better devices
to get you better theories right so we
see some of these loops
um the one that i really love actually i
should say it's not just about physics
right so we also see people connect
uh demography and uh agriculture
right uh you know births and deaths
right life spans uh child mortality
people start to realize this probably
has something to do with how people eat
right they connect agriculture to
geology
right whether your crops grow probably
has something to do with the underlying
rocks
right uh we see them connect uh
metabolism to
to actually to agriculture another one
metabolism because it's like the cow
eats stuff right
and it processes it and it you know
poops it out
and we should probably if we understand
that that'll probably help us explain
phenomena that we've noticed in
agriculture right and so on and so forth
good um so it isn't just the
you know it isn't just what we might
call the exact sciences that are linking
together
but also um you know these what we see
paleontology connect to botany right as
they start realizing that they can learn
about the
you know deep history of plant life it's
not just about dinosaurs
um so you know this this connection
stuff is is
is kind of all over the place um the
and i'll just i'll tell you the story
and then we could we could chat a little
bit more um
but uh the the one i really love
is okay so they connect electricity and
magnetism
right um the
but you know as we may remember right
light is a form of electricity and
magnetism
hertz's paper is in like our final issue
right before it goes under copyright or
whatever right so
you know at the end they've put this
together right they've linked
electricity
magnetism and light they realize this is
all
these things all go together but we can
see them make these connections we can
see them
start to connect magnetism and light
like
40 50 years earlier which is wild right
now what are they doing they're like
i there's this magnetic substance and i
shine light through it and like
something's weird happening like guys
help me out here right like
what is it about like magnetism seems to
be doing something
to light like what's right so you can
see them start to make those connections
um and so one of the things that you
know it brings up for us is can you sort
of look into the future
right so can you see where the next
advances are going to be now you know
that would be
in some sense you can't really do that
it's impossible to predict an
unpredictable future and
science is in some sense unpredictable
but it maybe gives us a sense at least
that
we're on the right track here as to
what's making for good explanations for
them and i do want to give you
um enough of a chance to talk about what
makes for terribly bad
explanations as well because it's a very
fun part
of what you've done i mean the different
values that you've pinpointed like we
said they compete against each other and
it can be in some sense not completely
algorithmic
how you weigh them against each other so
there's a failure mode where you
overvalue a particular kind of thing
and undervalue the others so why don't
you tell the timothy mcveigh story
i think that's a great example i really
like that one
yeah so there's okay i'll i'll tell you
two stories
um timothy mcveigh is a really
interesting one so this is the
conspiracy surrounding the oklahoma city
bombing
um you know this sort of the worst
terrorist attack on american soil
by that point 1995 white supremacist
attack
um so what happened well timothy mcveigh
and some co-conspirators
uh built a fertilizer bomb put it into a
u-haul truck
drove it to the federal building in
oklahoma city
uh set a bunch of timers um left it
there
it blew the building uh to pieces
many many people died um it was i mean
the devastation is quite shocking
actually reading about it in retrospect
we sort of forget
how insane it was um just one example
just the sort of horror of this is
um many people died just because of the
broken glass that flew
out from the explosion right so you know
the building also collapsed but so this
was
crazy um the other thing about this
attack
uh that's relevant here is that
no one knew who did it right this was
actually an extraordinarily
meticulously done thing right
at least at first you know they couldn't
you know
who you know who drove the truck where
did the bomb
come from there was they had no leads
um it was you know it was not um
[Music]
you know this there were not mistakes
made let's say
uh at least early on in this in this
investigation
so uh what happens well mcveigh you know
sets this bomb off and you know he walks
away it's on a timer
you know he's far enough away five
minutes later the thing blows up
mcveigh gets in the car and leaves so
he's in his car
the car he's driving doesn't have
license plates
on it he gets on the highway
and he starts speeding he gets pulled
over by a cop for not having license
plates and for speeding and the cop
notices he's got a firearm and it turns
out it's like an unregistered firearm so
he gets thrown in jail
and it's only when he's been in jail for
three days that they figure out it's him
so you know this great puzzle right how
could somebody
so you know able to pull off this plan
right this very elaborate plan be so
stupid right you know like even i know
this like
don't drive a car without license plates
and if you do
don't get on the highway and speed right
don't blow past a cup right
so you know how do you so you how do you
put this together right
the explanation of course you and i have
about the oklahoma city bombing and you
know spoiler it's true was that he was
essentially
an insane you know deeply evil person
who drew a few people in to help him
blow up this building
you know spurred by let's just call it
white supremacist rhetoric
right that's their explanation the
problem is
is that it's low in what we might call
descriptiveness
right it that explanation postulates
that timothy mcveigh was not a [ __ ]
at least in certain relative future
planning abilities
and yet he acts like a [ __ ] right
if you're not a [ __ ] doing what timothy
mcveigh did
after the bombing is a low probability
event right
so now our explanation is suffering on a
certain value
right it's suffering on this empirical
value of descriptiveness right
it's um you know it's like sag to go
back to our earlier example why is the
student taking french and neuroscience
together
ah because they're a romance language
major
okay well that actually makes the
neuroscience less likely because they
got other requirements right but your no
notes come on there's other reasons
so some people look at this
and you know they're told this story and
they say no i can explain that
it wasn't mcveigh mcveigh yes he's a
[ __ ] mcveigh was a patsy
right he didn't pull this off actually
all right let's go right actually it's a
government conspiracy and that you know
the
bureau of tobacco and firearms is
involved and you know so
they have an explanation which can
actually account for these facts they're
better at finding the data
they're better fits to the data right
and so you know of course what's coming
right what's going wrong for them right
i i can over fit to the data right and
so of course the theory they need
not only is strange not only does it you
know violate our domain dependent priors
and you know the joke is our domain of
enterprise like the government's not
that good at doing anything so how could
it do this right
but also it's violating these simplicity
priors because once you assume there's a
conspiracy
okay you know who else is in on it why
did the cops not see it well the cops
are in on it and the cop who wasn't got
shot in this mysterious way and
you know the newspaper guy is you know
he disappeared
so you know of course this this
explanation ramifies outwards
um that's a case where you know
we overvalue an anomalous point
yeah right or we over value dealing with
the anomalous point
that's a classic case from our point of
view of going extreme on that first
value
of descriptiveness the desire to make
sense of every last detail and
this is probably not true but uh i i
can't help but hypothesize
that this might have something to do
with one's fondness
for detective shows and novels right
because when you're when you're in a
mystery
fiction uh there are no coincidences
you'll hear the detectives say i don't
believe in coincidences and like every
fact turns out to be really really
important later on and i think that's
partly why uh alex rosenberg who's
another former guest on the show
oh yeah he likes to say that we make a
cognitive mistake by overvaluing stories
right we tell ourselves a story that
makes everything fit
sometimes things just happen right and
it's it's hard to
it's hard to weigh uh those two values
of admitting that sometimes things just
happen with the satisfaction you have of
fitting it all together into a matrix
i think that's right i mean there's um
you know i i can't remember if they let
us keep this but
um zach and i talk about one of the talk
about perhaps
yeah there's this enormous pleasure in a
detective novel when all the facts
are connected together right there's
this co-explanatory moment at the end
and you know it's
there's always the scene right you know
parvo brings everybody into the into the
room
um you know there's a great counter so
uh alberto echo
in his book name of the rose and this is
not a spoiler right but the name of the
rose is a great
this is mild spoiler name reverse is a
great book because in fact there is no
co-explanatory moment yeah
it doesn't it's a detective story
without co-explanation
um and of course i think echo actually
he he sort of talks about this a little
bit
uh you know maybe an introduction essay
ruined about it
um so that's a great example of how he
breaks the the convention but you're
right
um the you know alex says i think he's
got a piece of the puzzle here when he
talks about stories because stories
often
uh you know contain this co-explanation
that's what makes them appealing
um but there's also more so you know i
would say for example
um you know if we're right about how
these empirical values work
um you know you would expect conspiracy
theories to involve not just stories
but anomalous facts right so
you know this meme you know jet fuel
can't melt steel beams right which
also turns out not to be relevant but
it's a fact right so people are you know
that fact comes in as well as you know
dramatic accounts and stories and
narratives as well so there's this
empirical side
that i think you know we we can't
neglect um
these these little pieces that people
that people find attractive at least
seem to be part of the
part of the appeal and presumably things
like q and on or
flat earth beliefs are of the same
spirit where you're explaining a bunch
of things
i mean i guess flat earth is not quite
the same thing it's not a conspiracy
theory but
cubanon is like the classic it's the
epitome of explaining everything
by having a million moving parts in your
theory
right so i so let me this is a so you
know we we talked about one way to go
wrong right which is
this descriptiveness one let me talk
about the other one
um which is the the co-explanation going
wrong because
this is a different way that things can
break right
so that little fragment of the mcvay
oklahoma city bombing conspiracy theory
is clearly a case where people need to
fix
an anomalous piece right um you know jet
fuel can't mates
make melt steel beams fixes an anomalous
piece right
um co-explanation is a different appeal
and i think there's this is
partly working in q and on um i think i
can tell this story
um because i've told it once before i
but i won't this would be the last time
i tell this story because it's such a
good story i don't want to i don't want
to overplay it but
um i will give you an example of
co-explanation um
that i fell victim to shots yeah here we
go we all have
um we all have right so this was when i
first moved to santa fe
and um we you know i was in the cafe
and you know santa fe is full of very
interesting people some of whom are
crazy
uh one of the jokes is you know the
people in santa fe like they were so
disorganized that their car broke down
on the way to san francisco
right so you know that's your that's
your group
um and so i'm in the cafe and
my first week there and i meet this guy
and you know he sort of buttonholes me
and he starts telling me his conspiracy
theory
and you know i'm sort of don't make
enemies it's your first week in town
um so i'm listening right and he's the
conspiracy he's explaining to me and i
think
this this guy is long out of this right
but
you know at the time he was telling this
conspiracy theory known as the sovereign
citizens movement
so the sovereign citizens movement is a
conspiracy theory
that is so elaborate right that you know
i could
if i remembered i could tell you the
whole thing but just to give you a
fragment of it
uh it involves the idea that british
common law
in some way meant that the united states
government
in the 1800s could not borrow money
on the credit of the citizens like
somehow this
couldn't work right so what they did was
for every citizen they created a
fictitious identity
called your u.s name so everybody's
carrying around a fictitious identity
called the us name and it's the us name
identity that for example has to obey
the law right
um the us name identity is the one that
has to
pay taxes you yourself actually you
only it turns out our answer to like the
sheriff of your cap
i've never heard this one so i mean this
is sort of funny but it also obviously
you know the guy keeps going and i you
know eventually it turns into you know
obviously there's anti-semitic features
and all this right
one of the nice things about this
movement is people know it very well
because one of the things it tells you
to do is write a letter to the irs
telling them you're not going to pay
taxes
so it turns out they keep those letters
right
so you know this is it's a movement
that's relatively easy for the
government to track
so he's explaining this to me and i know
at some point i am waiting for it to get
dark
but he says look i'll tell you something
sorry i'll tell you about your u.s name
um you know the government has to deal
with you in your us name capacity all
the time
when it does um you know when you get a
letter or something like that
your name will be printed in all capital
letters um
right so this is i you know take your
wallet out sean do you have your wallet
i don't have it with me right now
okay so you know if your listeners do
this right you can test your you can you
can test your codex your co-explanation
problem here right
it's like you know your urus name the
government is it's all capitalized so
now take out your wallet it says look at
your driver's license
and my name's an all-capital letter oh
my goodness what about the past
and i was like for this moment sean i
was like oh just
there's something oh my god right
there's something to that no other way
so this is a
classic yeah it's a classic
co-explanation moment
uh because what he's done of course is
link all of these facts he's given me
about
a british common law or whatever it's
not that i believe this right but it's
like you know he's told me all about
jefferson
and then he's given me this story that
links
with this totally unexpected fact that
my driver's license has my name in all
caps right so this is now all connected
and it's this kind of lovely feeling
right you're like
the world very briefly got sort of
brighter and you know the colors got a
little brighter
um and then you sort of shake it off and
you're like no this is this is crazy
um but you know maybe i think the the
message or the larger message shauna is
um that you know these are values right
we have them
people who let's say fall victim to
these conspiracy theories
um and even if people even if someone
doesn't go crazy
there are some very negative features of
believing conspiracy theory
um one of them actually being that we
love to explain things to each other
it's a human like it's one of the things
we do all the time
if your explanatory values go wrong you
can't enjoy this with other people
right yeah so you know you and i sit
around and it's like i don't know sean
we would never have this conversation
was like what about the bulls you know
charcoal bulls are doing really well
this year
and it'd be like what's your theory well
let me explain it this way that way we
can have a lot of fun
but then the guy with the weird values
was like it's the jews
right and you're like hey like don't say
that that's
that's insane but also it's like that's
not how we that's not a satisfying
explanation even if it wasn't
right so you you lose this you lose this
ability to spend time with others
and people mention this so some studies
of q anon people
this is part of it is they sort of get
exiled from their friend groups
not even because you know because
they're being weird or sexist racist or
anything
but because they're they're just no
longer fun
to do this fundamental human thing with
right you can enjoy a sunset with them
but you can't explain why
you know trump won the election or why
um you know on sally's so upset this
week
um so these there are some real
downsides but
you know i think our message here is
that
those you know those stumbles those
falls that people have
you know they're not some alien
you know ridiculous access that's
completely orthogonal to you and i
yeah exactly right um that uh
you know their reasoning right their
reasoning
has gone wrong but they are still
reasoning they're not babbling
right and you know the question people
always ask us
is okay you've explained these things
can you predict
what to do about them or what
interventions will work and so the
answer is no we don't do prediction
but the explanation i think does
potentially you know
it gives us part of the puzzle because
if we see
the membership anything like q and on as
in part a disorder
of explanation making well how do we
you know how do we fix that right how do
we get people's values back into balance
um one piece and this is work that we've
been doing
when chloe perry and i have been doing
chloe's now at university of michigan
is the idea that you know you have weird
explanatory values
you can't hang out with your friends you
go on the internet
and what you do on the internet is not
just talk about jet fuel can't make
steel beams
but you also share and reinforce these
sort of malfunctioning values as well
so you're surrounded by people who don't
just believe crazy things but
also have the wrong meta principle for
adopting them
it suggests that you know part of this
is disconnecting people from
an epistemic value system as well as the
particular beliefs
right so it isn't just saying it's
ridiculous that you think timothy
mcveigh
was part of this conspiracy you know
that
people can be smart and idiots the same
day
um but also making sense of the way that
they're connecting things together in a
larger scale but right
part of what the problem is part of what
i thought you were saying
is that the actual set of epistemic
values
that the conspiracy theorists have is
the same set of values
that we very level-headed natural
scientists have
they're just weighting them different um
and
that sounds like a harder thing to i
mean or maybe it's an easier thing like
maybe since we rely on the same values
we can sort of uh
speak to those values and and bring
people back i don't know is there an
optimistic message here
um so uh i gave a talk actually zach and
i together gave a talk to the
philosophers at the university of
pittsburgh
right so pitt philosophy is like best
philosophy in the universe
um you know neo hegelian pragmatism
um sometimes but uh one of the people in
that seminar
uh made this lovely remark she's like
you have an aristotelian theory
of epistemic values meaning so you know
an aristotle it's all about this balance
right don't be foolhardy but don't be a
coward
right like where do you find yourself on
that continuum right
you know uh like you know weakness
versus strength
uh you you need to find some like the
the intelligence here the wisdom here
is finding the correct location on that
line
um not getting yourself killed but not
running from a fight you may need to
fight
um we have an aristotelian theory of
these
epistemic values they become virtues
when or you become let's say
epistemically virtuous
when you're at the right point here the
golden mean now does aristotle tell us
how to treat
you know anger maybe right people who
are too foolhardy people who don't take
enough risks
uh maybe uh but it it tells us maybe one
way in which
these these values are operating no i
mean that's actually really good like
i'm becoming more versatilian in that
sense
myself in the sense i mean not only is
it that you balance things
and you look for a harmonious uh middle
point but that
there is no algorithm for doing it right
that there is some kind of human choice
wisdom is the word you used uh
phronesis or something like that i'm
sure that uh the greeks would say but
but okay good so maybe let's to wrap
this up then um
sure yeah yeah put it to work let's like
do some worked example here
um what how would we think about let's
say
i have lots of work examples i can pick
from but let's say pan psychism versus
physicalism about consciousness so
here are two explanations for
consciousness one is that
the world is just protons and neutrons
and electrons obeying the core theory
and there's some higher level immersion
description and we call that
consciousness
there's another explanation in which no
no no i mean there's that stuff
and it obeys those laws but there's also
intrinsically mental
aspects of the physical stuff which are
not
captured by the standard laws of
particle physics etc
and those extra intrinsically mental
aspects are needed to explain
conscious experiences so here's two
explanations and you have a bunch of
values
and i can kind of i can imagine how i
would i would think that the physics one
is
simpler maybe but you know what would
you what would you say to someone who
wanted to evaluate these
using your values really right
i i love this example so much because
it's it's wonderful
so um you know let's let's let's deal
with the
with the like you know the property
dualism one right the pan psychism one
that says look there's just this other
property we all have
which is consciousnessiness um
you know this would be i would say a
highly descriptive theory
right um you know there's these things
and then there's these other things
and physics does these things and we
just have to stick in
right this other story here right
that they're not connected right there's
no co-explanation
um you know this conscious property is
in no way
correlated with that physical property
in any deep way
the you know it's the the properties are
live in distinct worlds of matter and
spirit
right so it's it's winning on
descriptiveness right
um it's not winning so much on
co-explanation
but you know i want to flip this around
now because i i know what you like i
know what i like which is this emergency
story right you know these
there's this you know there's this stuff
on the bottom here and it's like
bubbling up to produce these emerging
phenomena right
but that's actually it's not that simple
right
because how many layers between you know
quarks
and beliefs are there right
how many okay gosh i guess you have to
do the molecules and the molecules
okay so now you got to get the you know
the the substances and the
right there's a lot of space between you
know
the standard model and conscious
experience under that other one
so in that case you know that almost you
could make the pitch like that's a real
conspiracy theory
well right this is uh i make this point
in my recent quantum mechanics book
about
people who believe in let's say hidden
variables or pilot wave bohmian theories
versus people who believe in many worlds
um not only are they different theories
and they can argue which one is right
and we don't yet
know but also they both claim they have
the simpler theory
right but the the sense of simplicity is
different
uh and i think that this is one of the
reasons why i like your set of values
because i can see them coming apart the
the everettians will say look at my
equations there's only one there's
one equation that's all and everything
you just work on that equation and
massage it
and think about it really hard and you
get everything that's that's simplicity
for me and the bohmian say well no
look at the world and i can easily
locate it in my theory like there's
particles like there they are
in my theory i don't need all these
layers of explanation so that's what i
call simple but
maybe that's actually more
descriptiveness i'm not sure
i think i think that's actually i mean i
think that's a great way to distinguish
the many worlds from
these more like pilot wave things right
um
it's true you have to grind through a
lot of mathematics to get from the many
worlds to the classical world
right now um in one sense this is not
simple right like david wallace's book
is
500 pages um but if you think about this
as let's say a
program that you run right to derive
these things the program actually might
be quite
short yes in the sense that if you you
know you just have to be really smart
meaning you have to be
able to run that program quote-unquote
um but the program might be short
yeah so let me know there's the
shortness of the program but there's
also how long it's gotta run
right right yeah the logical depth they
call right how long the program runs
um all of these are you know it's these
are wonderful i think
um one of the pieces you know sean we
could talk about this forever right but
one of the pieces in the non-many world
stories right like the boeing story
i think a lot of this is domain
dependent priors oh yeah right
because i think one of the responses to
the many worlds it's like that's just
insane
right like come on right
and i think that's an appeal to let's
say
common sense right in the same way and i
just
keep going back to this you know aarons
and scott aronson's example of like
reasons why i won't read your proof and
again scott this is
you know this is a joke blog post right
but scott's like it would be ridiculous
if that's how you proved p
not equal to like come on
i think that's you know that's a
domain-dependent story there so i think
that's another piece
um it may also suggest why people have
been so resistant
to the many worlds theory over the years
is that you know we can we can convince
each other
that something's beautiful it turns out
right we can say okay this is more
beautiful than that and
we learn these values it may be much
harder to push around the tacit
knowledge it may be much harder to push
around
these these things that we've learned
that we don't even know we know
i like it right or we can't quite
articulate you know i think that's true
but i also think that
even when people share the tacit
knowledge this this way they balance the
different values
is is my favorite thing that i got out
of what you what you've been saying here
i'll give you one last example uh that
you can run with or not as you choose
lee smolin was very recently on the
podcast and
he said yeah he said something not on
the podcast but years ago that
that always really really struck me uh
because i couldn't it was
clearly true and i couldn't explain it
and maybe you're helping me explain it
he said
isn't it weird how people who believe in
the everett interpretation of quantum
mechanics
also always believe that computers will
someday be conscious
and it's not because everett implies the
computers will be conscious but the kind
of person
who's like yes just give me the simple
rules and i'll derive everything
is likely to by both everett and by that
consciousness is substrate independent
that's i mean you know this is
now this is a lab experiment one could
do on mturk if you could get enough
physicists
um or you know the irb to actually talk
to one
um you know i think this i don't know
sean i would again we could go on
forever but one of the things that i
think we've missed or
it's a big opportunity is to look at
these more let's call them exalted forms
of reasoning
right we we tend to look at sort of
minute level snap judgments that people
make
this is this tells us a lot but we're
missing kind of this we're missing sort
of the culture of explanation making and
that's
that's i think i mean i love this
example i think it would probably hold
up
we should run it at the next aps do you
know about the uh to ask people
the the fill
people.org the website um yeah for
philosophy
yes so david chalmers and david bourget
i guess
uh if you're a philosopher you can have
a profile site on fill
people and what one of the fun things
they do is they ask you your opinions
about all sorts of hot button
philosophical issues so you could
totally cross-correlate those
the data are there oh my god that's
amazing yeah no
the data is there i mean that's that
will i i will
we'll do that this afternoon because
that's that's a great example i'm sure
there's like 50 questions
and yeah you know philosophy tends to
have this
you know it's like do you believe in
analytic you know identity or do you
believe
who knows right like they've they have a
vocabulary there that enables
pretty simple binary well yeah and all
the all the questions are multiple
choice
so it's not like there's no essays so
it's like you know consciousness
physicalism psychism whatever it is
dualism and you know
quantum mechanics yeah
well that's good i always like i'm i'm
sold i love it i love it john this is i
like to end the podcast on an optimistic
note and there is no
more optimistic note than giving the
podcast guest work to do as a research
program so i'm glad
that we were able to do that climbing
the day oh thanks so much for being on
the windscape podcast
thank you shawn
[Music]
so
[Music]
you